unser wetter wird immer extremer dürren
schneestürme oder monsunartiger regen
fälle sogar hier bei uns und es wird
schlimmer
die ursache der polare get7 wird
langsamer welche katastrophalen folgen
das hat jetzt entwicklung einzusetzen
jetzt ist es amtlich unser wetter wird
sich dramatisch verändern
am nordpol hat sich die eisfläche in den
letzten jahren drastisch reduziert
dadurch gerät nicht nur mehr wasser in
die atmosphäre uns hier in europa hat
das bereits deutlich mehr regen und
schnee beschert es führt jetzt aber
zuviel weitreichenderen veränderungen
als bisher bekannt war
wie wir im moment am wetter chaos in den
usa sehen sind zustände wie im thema
katastrophen thriller the day after
tomorrow nicht mehr komplett utopisch
aber was ist passiert dass der
klimawandel zu solchen katastrophen
führt während in the day after tomorrow
das erliegen des golfstroms die
katastrophe verursacht ist die ursache
für die aktuellen unwetter die
veränderungen des polaren jobs dieser
jet stream ist ein dauerhafter wind den
acht bis zwölf kilometern höhe
denn mit windgeschwindigkeiten von bis
zu 500 kilometern pro stunde
unser wetter maßgeblich beeinflusst es
gibt einige jetstreams auf unserem
planeten allerdings hat der polare
jetstream der rund um den nordpol kreis
die größten auswirkungen auf unser
wetter
angetrieben wird er durch den
temperaturunterschied zwischen der
polarregion und den tropen und genau da
liegt das problem der nordpol ist in den
letzten jahren immer wärmer geworden
hier hat sich der klimawandel besonders
stark ausgewirkt während die globale
temperatur in den letzten 100 jahren so
um rund 0 85 grad gestiegen ist ist die
erwärmung am nordpol gut doppelt so hoch
besonders in den letzten jahren ist
deshalb die eisdecke dort extrem stark
zurückgegangen trauriger rekord war 2012
mit weniger als der hälfte der im
letzten jahrhundert üblichen eisfläche
für den polaren jetstream bedeutet das
weniger power
nach aktuellen studien hat er seit 1990
rund zehn prozent seiner burschen
geschwindigkeit eingebüßt und das hat
einen sehr unerfreulichen nebeneffekt
der polare jetstream variiert jetzt
stärker es gibt stärkere beulen im
stream
diese sogenannten rost rebellen die gab
es schon immer sie haben eine geringere
geschwindigkeit und bringen
extreme wettersituationen mit sich da
sie kalte oder warme luft von nord nach
süd und umgekehrt transportieren
das heißt dann wird es im süden deutlich
kälter und im norden deutlich wärmer
durch den verlangsamten jetstream werden
diese roski wellen jetzt auch langsamer
und bleiben dadurch stabiler
das heißt der jetstream transportiert
durch die stärker ausgeprägten wellen
die sich länger an einem ort halten
jetzt kalte luft viel weiter in den
süden und warme luft viel weiter in den
norden und das für deutlich längere
zeitperiode in zukunft haben wir also
mit immer mehr extreme wettersituationen
zu tun überflutungen schneestürme dürre
es wird verdammt ungemütlich auf der
erde nicht auszudenken wo das noch
hinführt was meint ihr ist das mit dem
klimawandel übertrieben
das war einfach viel zu viel bohei darum
gemacht oder werden wir hier bald
zustände wie in dem film sind day after
tomorrow haben und es drohen immer mehr
wetterkatastrophen diskutiertes in den
kommentaren mehr von klicks um
science-fiction gibt es hier
hier oben kernreaktor für zuhause
energie probleme gelöst kalte version
die link finden wir auch in der video
beschreibung genau so wie zu diesem
video aliens zehn gründe für ihre
existenz und zum blog geht's hier oben
oder in der video beschreibung ist der
link dafür auch und ich freue mich
natürlich über jeden neuen abonnenten
wer es noch nicht weiß tabus auf youtube
sind vollkommen kostenlos in diesem
sinne bis dann bleibt dran